progressives threatened to kill the
bipartisan infrastructure bill unless
moderates go along with their
budget-busting plans joe biden sneaks a
massive fine into the democratic budget
bill for businesses that don't force
vaccines on their workers and the biden
military infrastructure finally admits
joe biden's enormous afghanistan
screw-up i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
speaking of which it does not matter
what your politics are or who you voted
for everybody should have the right to
express themselves freely without big
tech using their information against
them this is one of the reasons i use
express vpn if you've ever wondered how
free to access tech giants make all
their money the answer is they track you
your searches and your video history and
everything you click on and they build a
profile on you and then they sell off
your sensitive data to advertisers for
example when you use the express vpn app
on your computer or your phone you
anonymize a lot of that online presence
by hiding your ip address that makes
your activity more difficult to trace
and sell to advertisers what's more
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your network
data to protect you from eavesdroppers
and cybercriminals what i like most is
how easy it is to use it takes just one
click to protect all of your devices
which is why expressvpn is rated number
one by both cnet and radar so let's stop
allowing big tech to revoke our rights
to free speech why not revoke their
right to your data instead secure your
internet with the same vpn i use for
online protection visit
expressvpn.com that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
dot com slash pen get three extra months
for free with that exclusive web link go
to expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more alrighty so
today is supposedly zero hour nancy
pelosi has said that she is going to
bring up for a vote the bipartisan
infrastructure package there is only one
problem which is that she probably does
not have the votes according to the new
york times democrats prepared
legislation on wednesday to avert a
government shutdown this week but
they're desperately trying to salvage
president biden's domestic agenda as
conservative leaning holdouts dug in
against an ambitious 3.5 trillion dollar
social safety net and climate bill that
carries many of the parties top
priorities always got to love the new
york times for that unbiased journalism
they're conservative leaning hold outs
right they're not moderates now they're
conservative leaning if you just oppose
spending 3.5 trillion randomly for no
reason this makes you a conservative now
which goods you know means much more
than half the country is conservative
presumably congressional leaders move to
address the most immediate threat
working to complete a bill to prevent a
government funding elapsed at thursday
and midnight
but after days of intensive negotiations
to bridge bitter differences in their
party over biden's two biggest
legislative priorities the president and
top democrats appeared as far as ever
from an agreement on their marquee
social policy package which the white
house calls the build back better plan
which in turn was imperiling a one
trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill that was scheduled
for a house vote on thursday so remember
what we have here is a failure to
understand what is going on by either
side of the political aisle within the
democratic side of the house you got the
progressives and the progressives are
basically
now threatening to shoot the hostage
here's the progressive plan which makes
no sense at all
the moderates in the senate want a
bipartisan infrastructure bill we will
not pass your bipartisan infrastructure
bill unless you vow to vote for this 3.5
trillion dollar budget bill that you
have said you're not going to vote for
so if the bipartisan infrastructure bill
comes up for passage we're going to vote
against it knowing that will then kill
our budget bills we want both of them
brought up at the same time and both
voted for or we're not going to vote for
your bipartisan infrastructure bill
meanwhile joe manchin and kristen cinema
along with a few moderates in the house
have said we're not big on this 3.5
trillion bill and if you bring them both
up at the same time will vote we will
vote the budget bill down
so democrats are having a very difficult
time bridging this gap and joe biden has
provided no leadership because of course
joe biden is not alive so that is a
major problem joe biden's lack of
aliveness is actually kind of it's kind
of stunning here because the people he
should be pressuring are the progressive
wing of his party he is utterly
incapable of standing up to the
progressive wing of his party this
should be a shock to anybody who watched
politics over the course of the last
couple of years
remember joe biden ran against bernie
sanders in the primaries bernie sanders
was the guy who was coming out of new
hampshire most likely to win the
democratic party nomination and then the
entire democratic party infrastructure
mobilized and joe biden won south
carolina and then he swept through the
rest of the primaries wiping sanders off
the board and he did so specifically
because people were very scared of both
sanders and his wildly left-wing agenda
so joe biden swept him right and then
he sort of ate his agenda and the
sanders agenda became the biden agenda
to the point where bernie sanders is now
basically driving the boat
bernie sanders is is essentially telling
house progressives to vote down the
bipartisan infrastructure bill unless he
gets the 3.5 trillion bill here is
bernie sanders doing just that yesterday
my fear is
that if the dual
agreement that was reached is broken and
we just passed the infrastructure bill
the leverage that we have here in the
senate to pass the reconciliation bill
will be largely gone i think the one
hope we have is to say look if you guys
want to pass the infrastructure bill i
want to pass it you want to pass that
you're going to have to deal with
infringe you're going to have to deal
with reconciliation you can't just keep
slow walking this thing
okay when the democratic party is
relying on bernie sanders for their
negotiation strategy they're out of
their minds bernie sanders has not been
at the head of a major piece of
legislation for his entire career and
the man's been in the senate since cato
was in the senate okay the man has been
in american government since well before
the foundation of the united states
republic and yet he still never passed a
major piece of legislation why because
he is a useless dullard when it comes to
actually negotiating deals with even
members of his own party
until five minutes ago bernie sanders
was considered a radical now he's
actually leading the party it's kind of
an astonishing thing and joe biden is
just sitting there caving into it which
is putting nancy pelosi in a rather
awkward position because
on the one hand she wants this
bipartisan infrastructure bill so that
biden has something to tout for the
midterms on the other hand she knows
that she may not get the bipartisan
infrastructure bill unless she forces
the moderates to vote in favor of a
budget bill and she ain't in control of
the senate in the first place so
democrats are trying to bring pressure
to bear on joe manchin and kirsten
cinema in the senate now before we even
get to the negotiations between
democrats over the bill i think it is
worthwhile noting a couple of things one
right now the american economy is sort
of on the brink this was not supposed to
happen
it was not supposed to happen remember
coming out of covid right as of january
the expectations were the united states
economy was going to grow maybe double
digits this year it was going to
certainly be somewhere between seven and
ten percent in terms of gdp growth it's
going to blow out all estimates instead
you have a shockingly slow economy for
what should be happening right now if
people who are not coming back to work
you have record rates of inflation and
now you have consumer confidence hitting
a seven month low
according to cnbc u.s consumer
confidence fell to a seven-month low in
september as a relentless rise in cover
19 cases deepened concerns about the
economy's near-term prospects fitting in
with expectations for a slowdown in
growth in the third quarter now remember
the entire media and the buy
administration are trying to convince
you of two things the reason for the
economic slowdown is not because of joe
biden's fiscal policy and it is also not
because of joe biden's coveted policy
the answer is it is because of both the
reason you're having an economic
slowdown is because the
bi-administration has been focused
solely and completely on blowing money
into an economy and paying people to
stay home which limits supply and drives
up prices right it creates inflation
that is currently outpacing whatever
wage increases people are seeing
inflation rates outpacing wage inflation
is called wage suppression okay that's
actually what is happening under joe
biden your wages are not going as far as
they would have earlier because of the
inflation rates that have been connected
to nearly every product and that is a
specific result of joe biden's loose
fiscal policy which has been pushing to
the federal reserve as well as joe
biden's extraordinarily loose spending
policy and which just wants to continue
to blow trillions of dollars into the
economy demonstrating once again the
shortcomings of demand side economics
the keynesian notion that if you just
keep pushing money into the economy no
matter what just ram it in there but
suddenly the economy will be healthier
as opposed to you're taking out useless
debt and redistributing wealth to a
bunch of garbage programs that are
essentially going to accomplish the
precise reverse of what they seek to
accomplish okay that is problem number
one problem number two is that joe biden
suggested he was going to end covid and
here is the thing covet for all intents
and purposes when it comes to government
policy now when it comes to the impact
of covet because the impact of lots of
things in life is not under the control
of government covid is over when it
comes to government policy the reason
covet is over when it comes to
government policy
is we now have vaccines this has been
true since literally february okay since
february it has been true that if you
were able to get a vaccine and you got
the vaccine and you were double dosed
you were good to go and joe biden was
never able to let go of the zero coveted
idea and so we are going to be stuck in
this morass for a very long time joe
biden wishes you to believe that the
delta surge that we saw in the south is
responsible for the bad economic showing
of his economy over the last quarter or
so the reality is that those states in
the south are growing faster than these
states in the north where they did not
see adults a surge and the reason for
that is because down south a lot of
people were like okay if i'm vaccinated
i get to go back to work and if i'm
unvaccinated and unworried and if i get
it that one's on me
that's coveted policy that's not covet
itself
just as the dramatic destruction of the
american economy last year was in large
part due to the policy response to covet
not covet itself right now that is 100
true it was it used to be maybe 60 true
because covey was still pretty dangerous
last year there was no good solution to
it you know if you were younger and you
could you're healthier maybe you could
wear a mask and go back to work and
still feel somewhat secure okay but now
that vaccines are available
coveted public policy's role is
basically over but joe biden insists
that covert public policy be at the top
of the heap so the destruction of the
american economy that is happening right
now
the attempt to ram through spending
combined with bad covet policy is
leading to economic stagnation and
inflation you're getting the stagflation
of jimmy carter beginning right now now
the economy is still growing it's not
that it has gone into full-scale
recession the way that it was during
some of jimmy carter's term
but
the there's a high likelihood that you
could see something like that happen in
the very near future because blue states
are still locked down and joe biden
wants to ram all the stuff through so
that is the predicate to these
negotiations which again are over a
massive spending package that is not
going to make things better it's going
to make things a lot lot worse because
in a second i'm going to get to what is
actually in these packages and the
administration's just lying to you
they're just lying to you what this is
all about
always and forever is make more
americans dependent on government so
that more americans will vote for
democrats so that more americans can be
dependent on government and we can move
slowly toward the social democratic
systems of sweden or norway and we can
slowly decline as a world superpower as
the world's economic leader and we can
become sort of a second-rate european
nation that's that's that's sort of the
goal here okay and then we'll all be
comfortable because equality will have
been reached of course america by the
way with the swedish system does not
look like sweden
the reason for that is because america's
not sweden and to try and simply
transplant all of the economic
institutions of sweden to the united
states would be radically unsuccessful
in a wide variety of ways you cannot
just take the same way you can't just
take american-style republicanism and
just drop it into afghanistan and say
it's going to work here you can't just
take all of the governmental systems
that are in place in places like sweden
and norway where they have very high
levels of cultural homogeneity where
they've extraordinarily high levels of
social fabric you can't take all that
stuff and just drop it in the united
states and expect that it's going to
work exactly the same way because it
absolutely will not it is worth noting
that when you look at sweden and norway
their life expectancy outpaced the
united states before they had any of
these socialistic systems in place over
there as of the 1930s and 40s they were
still outpacing american life expectancy
by about the same amount as they
currently outpace american life
expectancy for example and conversely if
you take swedish americans or nor or
nordic americans and you measure their
incomes in the united states versus
sweden or norway they're much higher in
the united states
okay so we'll get to what's actually in
these bills in just one second first let
us talk about a simple fact
you need life insurance if you are a
responsible person you need to make sure
your family is taken care of in case god
forbid something bad should happen to
you you know you're walking down the
street and suddenly a bunch of bulls
just comes running at you because you
didn't realize that you were actually
walking in pamplona and boom as they
just run right over you they're smacking
you in the face and it's bleeding and
screaming you realize i should have
listened to shapiro and gotten life
insurance from policy genius you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius in
fact you could save 1300 bucks or more
per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts at policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor higher than options from
ladder ethos and bestow getting started
is simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need you can compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
and policy genius doesn't add on extra
fees head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro gets started right now that's
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right okay so what exactly is in this
bill first of all democrats are lying it
is not in fact a 3.5 trillion bill it is
in fact a five to 5.5 trillion dollar
bill
the reason for that is because they are
using a bunch of budget tricks as the
wall street journal has pointed out
here's what the wall street journal
pointed out just a couple of days ago
the child allowance which is among the
bill's most expensive provisions extends
through the three thousand to thirty six
hundred dollar per child payments for a
decade it would cost 1.1 trillion
dollars but democrats hid the real cost
why they extended that allowance only
through 2025
right so they're lying they're saying
that this hugely expensive provision is
going to sunset in 2025. who thinks that
this provision is actually going to
sunset in 2025. have you ever met a
government program that has actually
sunsetted it doesn't happen okay
government programs as ronald reagan was
fond of saying are the only thing in
life that is guaranteed to have
everlasting life if you're searching for
the fountain of immortality if you're
searching for the fountain of youth and
immortality there is no better place to
find it than in a government program
democrats are also using a different
time shift to disguise the cost of their
medicare expansion says the wall street
journal new vision and hearing benefits
would kick in over the next few years
and cost about 20 billion bucks a year
but democrats are delaying the phase-in
of the dental benefit to 2028
which quote-unquote saves 420 billion
dollars over 10 years but then it phases
in in 2028 and boom
huge new costs which are not taken into
account because when you actually
measure the cost of the bill you do it
over a 10-year period so all you have to
do is set a time bomb off to go off in
year nine and then none of the costs are
measured in that 10-year period
then is the new universal child care
entitlement which gives 90 billion
dollars to the states but only from 2022
to 2027. the bill limits household costs
to a share of income on the sliding
scale none would pay more than seven
percent of income no matter how much
they earn or how many children they have
what happens when that 90 billion
dollars runs out which could occur
before 2027 well the bill then
automatically appropriates such sums as
may be necessary for each of the fiscal
years 2025 through 2027.
democrats are also charging states with
standing up a universal pre-k
entitlement which would start next year
and run through 2028.
biden's budget projects this new
entitlement will cost 33 billion a year
if fully phased in initially the feds
would pick up 100 of the cost but then
washington's share is supposed to
decline to 60 by 2028.
okay so that means the federal cost and
then it lowers where does the rest of
the costs go to the states so you get to
pay higher taxes at the state see you're
the same person paying state taxes and
federal taxes if they shift the cost
from the federal government to the state
government you still end up paying the
taxes you just end up doing it to the
state as opposed to the federal
government
democrats are also going to pay 100 of
average state tuition and fees for
students at community colleges in 2023
but 80 by 2027
but states are going to want to increase
their community college enrollment so
they're going to start picking up the
tab so bottom line is it is not 3.5
trillion it looks more like 5 trillion
to 5.5 trillion according to the
committee for a responsible federal
budget and it's not just that this bill
is a massive entitlement program
for a lot of people who by the way are
not quote unquote struggling or trying
to get by or poverty stricken
the expanded child tax credit as the
wall street journal points out has
become a monthly government check that
transfers large sums of money from
childless taxpayers to financially
secure middle class families and the
allowance is now 3 600 per child under
age 6 3 000 bucks for ages 6 through 17.
a married couple making 150 grand a year
with four kids would qualify for
thirteen thousand two hundred dollars a
year
the credits do phase out with income but
the same family earning four hundred
thousand dollars could still get up to
eight thousand dollars a year
and then biden says we need to tax all
those people
a new entitlement caps child care costs
at seven percent of income initially
that was limited to parents making 200
of the state's median income right so
the idea was that if you were paying
eight percent of your
income for child care then we would have
the government subsidize the other one
percent for example and that was
supposed to cap at like 200 percent of
the median income so if your state's
median income is 60 grand or 50 grand
you're talking about 100 or 120 grand
progressives got rid of the cap so now
it covers everybody
the u.s median income for a family of
four is now about 90 grand those
families would pay two percent of income
annually for child care 1800 bucks
taxpayers would pay the rest that's 21
000 for two kids in daycare according to
estimates by the heritage foundation in
wealthy states a family of four earning
200 grand a year could receive 23 grand
democrats also want paid family leave
about two-thirds of average wages for up
to 12 weeks a year for any family care
and reply to both part and full-time
employees and in the case of newborns
both parents are entitled to lead so
it's not maternity care
it's both right so my wife and i get to
take off 12 weeks and get two thirds of
our salary paid
this means a married couple with a
newborn each earning two hundred
thousand dollars
could collect more than one thousand
dollars in weekly benefits each
resulting in twenty four thousand
dollars of paid leave in one year
a couple making a hundred grand each
would each be eligible for roughly the
same amount
democrats are also expanding obamacare
and they are expanding it downward in
terms of who it is applicable to the
bill includes an electric tax credit for
twelve thousand five hundred dollars
which is a huge chunk by the way you see
a lot of poverty-stricken people driving
around electric vehicles driving around
those teslas do you who do you think
that tax credit's gonna go to
and then of course nancy pelosi wants to
exempt all of her blue state friends
from the consequences of their own
foolish fiscal actions she wants to get
rid of the state and she wants to
replace the state and local tax
deduction so you'll recall that the
trump tax bill
got rid of you being able to deduct your
state taxes against your federal taxes
because that was really a cheap and easy
way for democrats to basically subsidize
blue states if you had a 13 state tax
rate in california you could deduct
before trump's tax plan you could deduct
your state taxes before looking at your
top line income and then paying your
federal income based on that
trump got rid of that so you use the
same top line income
for both your federal taxes and your
state taxes because otherwise what
you're basically doing is you are you
are benefiting all of the states that
have high state tax rates while
penalizing states like florida that have
a zero percent state tax rate nancy
pelosi wants to replace that
specifically in order to benefit her
blue state friends
this bill is a boondoggle everybody
knows that is a boondoggle and so
democrats are going to try and convince
you that the dollar cost on this is zero
i mean this is an audacious lie now the
real reason the democrats are telling
this lie you've seen joe biden tell it
you've seen chuck schumer tell it now
you're saying nancy pelosi tell it the
cost of this bill is zero the reason
they're saying this is because they
understand that the republicans are
saying we're not going to raise the debt
ceiling while you blow out the spending
and so democrats are like they're two
separate issues our new spending is not
even gonna raise the debt
um number one it will and number two
when you say that it is cost free or
that it costs zero dollars
that is lying here's nancy pelosi
the president is negotiating as is well
known i keep reading it in the daily
metropolitan journal about that and it
is what is happening and we're hoping
that we can come to a place it's not
about a dollar amount the dollar amount
as the president said is zero this bill
will be paid for it's about what are the
values that we share and how we
prioritize them and that is the place
that we will go
the dollar amount is zero okay this is
the line they're actually gonna go with
the dollar amount is zero and joe biden
tweeted out the other day that instead
of wasting money on tax cuts we could be
making investments and all of this is a
perversion of the english language it's
the equivalent of the democrats telling
you okay nancy pelosi's walking down the
street while it's hanging out your back
pocket
she just steals your wallet and in your
wallet 100 bucks she says i could give
you back this 20 but that would be
wasting money
instead i'm going to take this hundred
dollars and i'm going to spend it
essentially buying votes i'm going to
call that an investment so the choices
are i can waste money
by giving you back some of your money
and still stealing the rest or i can
spend all of it on random garbage that
basically helps me electorally and i
will call that an investment
this is the plan this is their big plan
now here's the thing
democrats are kind of jacked either way
if they don't pass this thing they look
incompetent if they do pass this thing
the consequences fiscally for the future
are pretty dire they are not good
now joe biden doesn't care because he
doesn't have any long-term vision now
john maynard keynes once said that in
the long run we're all dead well for joe
biden it ain't the long run and he
understands that his legacy is very much
tied to what happens right here but he's
not really leveraging any bit of his
presidential power to get the
progressives to fall in line and at
least get something done here which is
kind of astonishing all of this is
predicate to the fight between the
progressives and the moderates the media
are all on the side of the progressives
so the progressives are very very angry
at christian cinema and joe manchin
because kirsten cinema is in a purple
state and so kirsten cinema
refuses to go along with this 3.5
trillion dollar
budget boondoggle same thing with joe
manchin who's in the red estate in
america he's refusing to go along with
it as well and the progressives are
saying we will kill your dreams of this
bipartisan infrastructure bill
if you don't give us what we want on the
budget
so
they are just basically threatening to
do something that will not result in
what they want if they shoot the hostage
they don't get anything i mean and it's
they have no leverage over mansion and
cinema in any real way here they're
trying to do it anyway according to
politico it is an article of faith among
most democrats the progressives will
always cave to their more centrist
colleagues when the time comes to vote
on major legislation and yet on the
brink of a historic bout of
congressional chaos the exact opposite
appears to be happening
over the past few days the left has been
galvanized by the idea of voting down
the bipartisan infrastructure package
unless their moderate counterparts first
provide some commitments on the party
line social spending and climate bill
that sentiment could change at any
moment but there's one reason it might
not instead of facing the usual
chastisement from prominent democratic
leading pundits progressives are being
cheered on for their intemperance
yup so you have jamal bowie of the new
york times tweeting his endorsement
either both bills pass or neither does
okay honestly like go for it man cut off
that nose to spite your face i'm i'm
into it
for progressives it's been lovely if a
bit bewildering to watch it's a
beautiful sight said rebecca katz a long
time progressive operative
this is the most together they've been i
mean i can't remember the last time
we've seen something like this i've been
retweeting jonathan chait and hillary
clinton people today it's very confusing
well it's not really confusing because
you have to understand that democrats
see the prospects of them being able to
do anything at all beyond next year's
elections has basically gone and so it's
get things done while the getting is
good and so when they look at mansion
and cinema who both wish to hold their
seats
instead of saying to themselves you know
what a little bit of incrementalism
might go a long way they've said we are
going to go for broke
now maybe this comes from just an
outside sense of confidence in the
aftermath of biden's victory
there's an outside sense of confidence
among democrats after 2012 that they
would never lose an election again and
then of course they lost the election of
2016.
the democrats seemed to have the same
feeling in 2020
and then 2022 is going to happen
if they were not quite so confident they
might have approached this in some sort
of incremental fashion pass the
bipartisan infrastructure bill come back
to another bill that's two trillion
dollars probably get that instead
they've decided to go for broke because
they feel like if we don't do something
big and splashy right now then how can
we hold our heads high even as we enter
minority status and so they are very
very angry at christian cinema
so according to the new york times
christian cinema is at the center of it
all some arizonans wish she weren't well
there's only one problem kristen cinema
still holds 56 approval rating among
democrats in arizona
so she's doing fine
but the new york times is trying to
press cinema and the media our journal
activists are trying to push these
democratic moderates into abandoning
their positions this is why every 30
seconds for the last
seven months eight months nine months
they've been asking mansion and cinema
whether they are going to kill the
filibuster and every 30 seconds
manchester are like nope
and so the media come back 30 seconds
later like have you changed your mind
yet they're like my kids in the car on
the way to disneyland no we're not there
yet no we're not there yet okay mansion
and cinema are not gonna get there
according to the new york times
when miss cinema famously gave a thumbs
down to a 15 minimum wage and refused to
eliminate the filibuster to pass new
voting rights laws this year jade duran
a democrat and biomedical engineer from
phoenix decided she was fed up she
joined dozens of liberal voters and
civil rights activists in a rowing
series of protests outside miss cinema's
phoenix offices which have been taking
place since the summer nearly 50 people
have been arrested it really feels like
she doesn't care about her voters said
mr rand 33 who was arrested in july at a
protest i will never vote for her again
well there's only one problem which of
course is that if she had the green
party activists backing her then she
probably would not be able to win in
arizona remember kristen cinema very
narrowly won her seat she was not
supposed to win her seat because of all
of her bad old comments about everything
ranging from the war in afghanistan to
lgbt issues and then there was she won
and now she's turned out to be one of
the more moderate members of the senate
and so she will probably hold her seat
or at least she has a very good shot of
holding her seat
but according to the new york times
she's facing a growing political revolt
at home from the voters who once counted
themselves among her most devoted
supporters she doesn't care the reason
she doesn't care is because these are
not the people who are going to make or
break her see cinema understands
something that joe biden clearly doesn't
which is where her bread is buttered her
bread is not buttered by the people who
are protesting outside her office her
bread is buttered by the people or the
swing voters in the state of arizona
i mean frankly i hope that the
progressives get their way and they
knock over cinema and they nominate
somebody who's really radical and then
they lose the seat that would be good
that's fine with me
but it's amazing to watch as the as the
radical left goes after kristen cinema
and joe manchin as well we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact you don't want to go to
the auto parts store because who wants
to go to the auto parts store like what
the hell's the point you stand there for
a really long time finally gets to the
front of the line and then there's some
guy who really doesn't know what he's
talking about and he stands there he has
to call his manager because you need a
specific part and he's like bro
we don't have it it's out of stock it
turns out beto works behind the counter
he's like yeah we gotta order it yeah
bro
and you're like um when will it be in
two weeks it'll cost you 300 extra
dollars okay or i could just go online
at rockauto.com at home and just do this
myself rockauto.com always offers lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear the way that airlines do why spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
furthermore prices at rockauto.com are
always the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you all righty so the
progressive wing has been assailing
kristen cinema apparently in the odd
belief that if they please meddy hassan
on msnbc that somehow this is going to
get kristen cinema to change her mind
which is really really dumb
honestly it's the equivalent of people
fulminating on fox news about susan
collins like i can fulminate as much as
i want about susan collins and collins
ain't listening to me
susan collins has her set of voters
she's not particularly interested in
what those of us on the the
quote-unquote hard right have to say
okay it's the same thing when it comes
to corey bush ripping on chris like what
in the world would christian cinema care
about cory bush a black lives matter
activist and adjunct member of the squad
why why would she possibly care but
it's great virtue signaling time for
corey bush
it is sickening to me that there are
people who will just uh push aside those
that need these deep housing investments
what we're talking about is saving lives
right now we need the we need that
prescription drug reform and to say oh
you know what you can continue to have
to worry about whether you're going to
pay your rent or or or get the um the
life-saving medications that you need
because you know what my donors are the
ones who have been here you know it's
sickening but i am i'm speaking to her
humanity and i hope she hears me
it's sickening i'm speaking out for
humanity she's evil she wants people not
to have homes i hope she listens to me
yeah
strategic acumen there from corey bush
just brilliant brilliant stuff in media
hassan not he tweeted out this very
powerful stuff very powerful yes i'm
sure it's very powerful in doing nothing
congratulations there ro khanna who's
been a guest on the program very nice
guy but rokhana uh he he did the same
thing on msnbc with the inimitable joy
read here we go
why did senator cinema create this
deadline that if we don't do something
on thursday i'm going to walk i mean who
legislates like that
she's a first-term senator i mean if as
a first-term member of the congress or
even a third-term member of congress if
i said if i'm not going to get my way
i'm going to walk the speaker would
laugh at me understandably these
politics is a team sport and at the end
of the day we have to act on behalf of
the american public and we have to
understand we have a president president
biden we have a speaker of the house and
senate majority leader they've been
there for many years they have
experience we can disagree but have some
respect and have some sense that there
is a coach and someone's in charge of
the team
but no nobody is in charge of the team
they have 50 seats in the senate 50 plus
one that's it okay that means that every
single senator is the swing vote for the
democrats and by the way if rochon or
the swing vote in the house he'd be
using that power the same way the
progressives are the progressives are
using their power right now to hold up
the bipartisan infrastructure bill why
does the logic only work one way
so the democrats are getting desperate
dick durbin the senator from illinois is
like just name your price just tell us
what you want please okay here's the
thing manchin and cinema said what they
wanted and then the progressives in the
house are the ones holding it up but it
is amazing how nobody in the democratic
party will just say boo to the
progressives nobody will say listen it
is your responsibility to vote for the
bipartisan infrastructure bill that is
widely popular and then we'll talk about
this 3.5 trillion dollar bill
right nobody will say this to them
because they're so scared crapless of
their progressive wing which is why they
are in serious trouble here
i think we've shown a lot of respect to
our colleagues who obviously have a
different point of view when it comes to
reconciliation there's been meaningful
negotiation that's going on for weeks
the president has been involved
personally i've never seen a president
engaged this way since barack obama's
days with the affordable care act so
we're all in all aboard now it's time i
would say for both senators make your
mark and close the deal what is it that
you want what is your final goal it's
time to stop talking around it and speak
directly to it
um what do they want they've made very
clear what they want in fact joe manchin
i mean i could say that joe manchin put
out like a very long statement
explaining precisely what he wants
manchin said quote every member of
congress has a solemn duty to vote for
what they believe is best for the
country and the american people not
their party respectfully as i've said
for months i can't support 3.5 trillion
dollars more in spending when we already
have spent 5.4 trillion since last march
at some point all of us regardless of
party must ask a simple question how
much is enough by the way he's not wrong
unemployment rates rose the unemployment
filings again rose for the third
straight week to 362 000 this week
why because you're paying people to stay
home because you're inflating the
currency
because you're inflating the prices
because you're doing a terrible job and
your drought and your your solution to
this is you blow more money into this
economy manchin said proposing a
historic expansion of social programs
while ignoring the fact we are not in a
recession and that millions of jobs
remain open we'll only feed a
dysfunction that could weaken our
economic recovery this is the shared
reality we all now face and it is this
reality that must shape the future
decisions we as elected leaders must
make
and then he talked about how careless
spending was going to make things worse
he says
since the beginning of this
reconciliation debate i've been
consistent in my belief any expansion of
social programs must be targeted to
those in need not expanding beyond what
is fiscally possible our tax code should
be reformed to fix the flaws of the 2017
tax bill and ensure everyone pays their
fair share but it should not weaken our
global competitiveness or the ability of
millions of small businesses to compete
with the amazons of the world overall
the amount we spend now must be balanced
with what we need and can afford not
designed to re-engineer the social and
economic fabric of this nation or
vengefully tax for the sake of wishful
spending in august says joe manchin i
recommended we take a strategic pause to
provide time to develop the right
policies and to continue to monitor how
the pandemic and economic factors are
affecting our nation's fiscal situation
before we spend more throughout
september i've made it clear to all
those who would listen the needs to
means test any new social programs who
are helping those who need it the most
not spending for the sake of spending
while i am hopeful that common ground
can be found that would result in
another historic investment in the
nation i cannot and will not support
trillions in spending or an
all-or-nothing approach that ignores the
brutal fiscal reality our nation faces
there is a better way i believe we can
find it if we're willing to continue to
negotiate in good faith if there's one
final lesson that will continue to guide
me in this difficult debate it's this
america's a great nation but great
nations have been weakened by careless
spending and bad policies hey that is a
pretty obvious not doing this from joe
manchin by the way he then doubled down
on that and he said
i'm not going to vote for this bill if
it doesn't have the height amendment in
it so democrats have stripped out the
hyde amendment which is federal funding
for abortion
he was asked about this by national
review
and uh he said that's dead on arrival if
they take out the height amendment
okay so meanwhile kristen cinema right
who's being bashed about
i will say she is a she's a snark fest
kristen cinema she's pretty hilarious so
cinema apparently uh was asked by frank
thorpe a reporter with nbc news about
all of this
she said the the reporter said what do
you say to progressives who are
frustrated they don't know where you are
and cinema said i'm in the senate
and thorpe said there are progressives
in the senate that are also frustrated
they don't know where you are either
and cinema said i'm clearly right in
front of the elevator
[Music]
okay here's the thing the progressives
know exactly where she is that's her
point her point is i'm right here i'm in
the senate and guess who i'm not
answerable to progressives in the house
progressives in the house in just a
second we're gonna get to joe biden's
coveted policy which again
if there are two reasons why the economy
is stagnating right now it is his fiscal
policy and in his code and it is his
covet policy and they are not
disconnected we'll get some more on that
in just one second first let's talk
about a different kind of sponsor for
this particular episode the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast you really
should be listening to i know that every
day somebody tells you you have to
listen to some podcast and you're not
you're like sure and then you don't
listen to it
well don't let that happen with jordan's
show which is totally worth it jordan's
show apple named it as one of its best
of 2018 it's aimed at making you a
better informed more critical thinker so
you can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain each episode is a
conversation with a different
fascinating guest when i say there's
something for everyone here i really
mean that in one episode jordan talks to
a hostage negotiator from the fbi who
offers techniques on how to get people
to like and trust you that sounds useful
and somewhat disturbing at the exact
same time also has a bunch of really
interesting conversations with different
people ranging from scott adams to dan
carlin i don't always agree with jordan
but he always is interesting we here at
daily wire enjoy the show we know you
will too there's a lot here check out
jordanharbinger.com
start
for some episode recommendations or
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b is in boy innis and nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts alright
we're going to get to more in just one
second joe biden doubling down on his
garbage cove policies first if you're a
video editor whose dream it is to work
here at the incredible unparalleled
daily wire now is your chance we're
searching for a new video editor to join
our post-production department in
beautiful nashville tennessee this
person will cut and assemble raw video
footage using compelling storytelling
skills to creatively support and
emphasize subject matter and videos for
various daily wire projects and shows
like this one a minimum of two years
previous professional video editing
experience is required for this
opportunity this is a nashville
tennessee based position and if you
don't live in national tennessee should
think about relocating it's a great
place to live to apply please submit
your resume as well as a link to your
real or portfolio through dailywire.com
careers a full list of our current
openings at dailywire can also be found
at dailywire.com
careers also if you're a fan of
dailywear backstage i've got excellent
news for you this october not only will
we be live and on stage at the famous
ryman auditorium in nashville we are
also giving one lucky member a chance to
win two vip tickets to get front row
seats not just that the winner gets a
1500 gift card to cover travel expenses
a meet and greet with the backstage
hosts and more hurry because today is
the last day to enter tickets for the
ryman show are sold out already this is
your one and only chance to get in on
the action join one of our membership
plans with code backstage for 25 off if
you're already a member you will be
automatically entered to win so get
ready because you might just be on your
way to nashville to meet me jeremy
boring michael knowles matt walsh andrew
clavin and candace owens next month and
remember today is the last day to enter
so if you don't want to miss out make
sure you enter right now you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so as i've said joe biden's economy is
not doing well okay it should be booming
right now remember before he took office
i said that joe biden had been handed
just a world of joy right really he he
had because we had a vaccine vaccine was
going to be put out there
millions of people are going to get it a
lot of people are going to be immune we
were reaching the end of the pandemic
the artificial
destruction of the economy in 2020 was
going to simply go away we were going to
have massive economic growth for the
next two years this was my prediction
joe biden has somehow singularly screwed
up all of that inside of nine months and
then added on top of that in afghanistan
disaster to boot so the other half of
the fiscal policy disaster that is the
biden administration is the covet policy
disaster that is the biden
administration and much of that has to
do with the attitude that joe biden has
taken toward public policy with regard
to covet now here's the reality the cova
vaccines are extremely effective in
preventing hospitalization and death if
you're above the age of 65 then you
probably should consider getting a
booster that is not a huge deal okay the
fact is that it usually takes a couple
of rounds of mmr in order for your kids
to be immune to mmr so is that the end
of the world does that prove that
vaccines aren't ineffective no it
doesn't okay and the reality is even if
you don't get a booster these vaccines
remain highly effective against
hospitalization and particularly against
death and that's been true yes including
places like israel the reason so many
people who are vaccinated have been
hospitalized in israel is because pretty
much everybody in israel has been
vaccinated okay so you're getting like
the most vulnerable people who have been
vaccinated maybe a fraction of those
people are getting really ill okay so
the vaccines are super effective which
means once you've had the choice to take
the vaccine or not take the vaccine it
really is nobody else's business unless
you are in the situation which so many
people have chosen not to take the
vaccine that it is overwhelming the
hospital and then you're back in sort of
the situation that you had at the
beginning of the pandemic where in order
to avoid
unnecessary death at the hospitals
because of lack of resources you need to
have things like mass mandates or
lockdowns or something right that was
the same logic that was originally used
in march of 2020
but so long as the hospitals are not
being overwhelmed this pandemic in terms
of public policy is essentially over not
in terms of damage to people in terms of
public policy joe biden cannot accept
that
because joe biden set himself a goal
that is unachievable and he's making the
unachievability of that goal core to his
entire program
i mean he was asked
over the last couple of days what
percentage of americans would have to be
vaccinated for us to go back to normal
life as well he was getting his booster
shot because joe biden is 127 years old
here here is joe biden explaining what
percentage of americans must be
vaccinated frustrated quote unquote go
back to
normal like what is the percentage of
total vaccinations
well i think
look
i think we get
the vast majority like just going on to
some of the some industries and some
schools
97 98
i think we're awful close and uh
but i'm not the scientist uh
i think but one thing for sure
a quarter of the country can't go on
vaccines
and let's not continue to have a problem
okay a quarter of the country can't go
unvaccinated and us not have a problem
who's us
right who is us the people who are
unvaccinated don't have a problem in
their own minds because they decide not
to get vaccinated 75 of people who are
vaccinated are vaccinated so who the
hell are you talking about 97 98
of the people getting vaccinated who
does it does he actually think that's
going to happen or anything remotely
like it there's not a scientist in
america who thinks that's going to
happen
so if you set as your baseline you have
to get 97 98 of people vaccinated in
order for joe biden's economy to succeed
and us to go back to quote unquote
normal
you're gonna end up some pretty crazy
policy and by the way you are ending up
with some pretty insane policy so right
now for example new york has this
vaccine passport that's being used now
we know these vaccine passports are not
supremely effective okay the israeli
health ministry was caught on a hot mic
saying yeah they're not effective we're
just trying to get people to vaccinate
okay but broadway returned okay in new
york they have these vaccine
cards you're supposed to show
broadway returned
wednesday night's performance of aladdin
was canceled why because there were
positive cova tests within the cast and
crew not that anybody was symptomatic
not that they sent home the symptomatic
not that everybody else got to stay
they closed the entire show
they closed the entire show 24 hours in
because of a breakthrough covid case
which is not going to kill or
hospitalize anybody
okay this is crazy this is crazy towns
you think that that somehow broadway's
remained open during flu season when
everybody's shouting and spitting on
each other like gary oldman in an old
episode of friends
this is
somehow they've been able to survive for
you know
a hundred years on broadway with many
outbreaks of various diseases and yet
this is what is shutting them down is
breakthrough cases of covet among the
vaccinated
if that's your logic you end up in crazy
town and joe biden is ending up in crazy
town i mean he's already in senile town
now he has taken the way station stop in
in crazy town as well
one of the things that he has leveraged
into this budget bill
is a tenfold increase in fines for
employers who willfully repeatedly or
even seriously violate a section of
labor law that deals with hazards deaths
or serious physical harm to their
employees
in other words if a company over 100
employees does not mandatorily vax their
people or get them tested every week and
then testify to the federal government
that they are doing so
the fines could run as high as seventy
thousand dollars for serious infractions
and seven hundred thousand dollars for
willful willful or repeated violations
three-quarters of a million dollars for
each fine
each fine bankrupting essentially every
mid-sized business in the united states
that doesn't force down a vaccine
mandate on people
or fire everybody who's not vaccinated
the biden administration is already
starting to implement the vaccine
mandate enforcement blueprints according
to forbes.com osha said precedent this
summer they published that emergency
kova 19 rule in the federal register
early in september biden announced that
100 or more employee coveted 19 vaccine
mandate by the way you'll notice
something the osha rules don't apply to
customers
right there's nothing that says you you
have to
vax screen people who enter your
establishment
which for most businesses particularly
retail businesses that's a lot of people
coming into your business who may or may
not have coveted
the legislative provision passing the
budget committee raises those fines ten
times higher and up to seven hundred
thousand for every willful or repeated
violation
if the legislation is enacted osha could
levy draconian fines to enforce that
vaccine mandate this would employ this
would uh
hit an estimated 80 million workers
okay so that's what's in this this
garbage bill
and then they wonder why people are are
acting afraid why the economy isn't
going back to normal because you're
scaring the living hell out of them
now i know people who are triple vaxxed
and are still acting as though they are
going to die they're walking around with
kn95s after being triple vaxxed not
because they're afraid of infecting
other people because they themselves are
afraid of getting infected which i'm
sorry is crazy that is not risk
assessment that's just you being crazy
according to the associated press
bronwyn russell wears a mask any time
she leaves her illinois home but she
wouldn't dream of going out to eat or to
hear a band play much less setting foot
on a plane oh a plane by the way planes
have not been a vector of transmission
this entire time they have hepa filters
in virginia oliver rarely done's
mask never lets cover 19 rounds any
worry and happily finds himself in
restaurants and among crowds she is
vaccinated he is not right as i have
said people who are unvaccinated are
typically not worried people who are
vaccinated seem to remain worried
a poll of people aged 50 or older found
36 percent are very or extremely worried
that they or a family member will be
infected roughly doubled since june the
increase is fueled by the vaccinated who
are especially likely to be highly
worried
just 25 percent of vaccinated americans
but 61 of unvaccinated americans say
they are not worried
that is because of joe biden and because
of joe biden alone he lost he lied about
the risks to the facts he literally said
to the american people you have to worry
about whether you yourself are going to
be infected by an unboxed person after
being vaccinated he said we have to
protect the vax from the unvexed isn't
that what the vaccine is supposed to do
wasn't that the point of the vaccine
this is why you end up with the worst
possible result unvexed americans who
should be more afraid which would prompt
them to get the vaccine are not worried
and vast americans who should be back to
living normal life and supporting the
economy and supporting their families
they're freaking out
because of joe biden because of joe
biden because he is an incompetent
already well to back all of this to to
back all of this and to try and cuddle
people into getting vaccinated whether
or not they would like to do so the
biden administration continues to push
on all fronts
their latest front is they're pushing
pregnant people to get vaccinated now
i have family members who are pregnant
who have asked about covet vaccination
i've have friends who are who are
pregnant who have asked about code
vaccination or about to get pregnant
they've asked about covered vaccination
and what i've told them is the best
available data shows that the vaccines
are not only
safe for pregnant people to take best
available not all data red game we don't
have longitudinal data best available
data shows that the covid vaccines are
less dangerous to your pregnancy then
covet itself you're more likely to get
sick and get your baby sick if you have
covid than you are if you get the
vaccine
right that's best available data so far
as i'm aware
and doctors like marty mccary from johns
hopkins university who's been our go-to
throughout the pandemic he has said that
pregnant women particularly
after the first trimester should think
about getting the covet vaccine dose one
and then if you can delay those two
until after you've had the baby then
that might be the smartest possible
choice right that's sort of been his
advice
okay now the cdc is coming out and
saying that pregnant women should get
vaccinated now
by best available evidence i agree
here is the problem here's how the cdc
phrased this on twitter you ready for
this
pregnant people with symptomatic
covenant have a 70 increased risk of
death only 31 percent of pregnant people
have been vaccinated against covid19 get
vaccinated find a cova-19 vaccine near
you vaccines.gov
so um i have a question
am i supposed to trust you guys on
science when you use the term pregnant
people
pregnant people
you scientific experts out there
what you mean like my dad's gonna get
pregnant
i'm going to get who are these pregnant
people of whom you do you mean women
do you mean pregnant women because men
cannot get pregnant the same morons who
will tell you follow the science are
constantly yelling in your ear that men
and women are completely malleable
categories that do not exist when in
every major mammalian species there is
sexual dichotomy which provides the
basis for reproduction and here you are
talking about the actual reproductive
capacity we're not even talking about
difference between men and women in the
workplace we're talking about actual
reproductive capacity which is the
defining feature of male versus female
and you can't even say female
and then you're telling me i need to
trust you on the science i have
questions i think a lot of people have
questions
it's amazing how few of these people are
willing to look in the mirror and take a
little bit of blame for the fact that
they've completely debunked their own
credibility and by the way if you then
suppress conversations about this stuff
you're not you're not helping yourself
so youtube has now announced
that they're going to ban anti-vaxxed
activists from youtube now again there's
no one on the right who's more pro
vaccine than i am you go back to 2015. i
was talking about vaccine mandates for
childhood diseases i was talking about
how pro-vaccine i was and how the
anti-vaxx movement was a real problem in
the united states
okay so there you will find no one on
the right who's more openly pro-vaccine
than i am
it is patently crazy for you as youtube
a platform to be banning quote-unquote
anti-vaxx content in the name of somehow
getting people to vax you think all the
people who are watching that anti-vaxxed
content now that you've banned it are
going to think oh well you know they
banned it on youtube i guess now i
believe them
suppression of viewpoint is typically a
very bad way of convincing people who
are curious about the viewpoint that the
viewpoint is bad it usually makes them
more curious about the viewpoint
youtube has apparently taken down
several video channels associated with
high profile anti-vax activists like
joseph mercola and robert f kennedy jr
who experts say are partially
responsible responsible for helping seed
the skepticism that's contributed to
slowing vaccination rates across the
country as part of a new set of policies
aimed at cutting down on anti-vax
content on the google own site youtube
will ban any videos that claim that
commonly used vaccines approved by
health authorities are ineffective or
dangerous the company previously blocked
videos that made those claims about
covert vaccine but not for ones like
measles or chickenpox
misinformation researchers have for
years said the popularity of
anti-vaccine content on youtube was
contributing to growing skepticism of
life-saving vaccines in the united
states and around the world vaccination
rates have slowed about 56 percent of
the us population has had two shots
compared with 71 percent in canada and
in the uk
and of course president biden is blaming
social media companies as opposed to his
own institutional lack of credibility
you'll notice the partisan gap in terms
of vaccination rates that is not a giant
surprise considering the people who
trust the media are taking the vaccine
and the people who don't trust the media
are not taking the vaccine as much now
people across the board should be taking
the vaccine but if you think that then
suppressing alternative sources of media
is going to be the way that you actually
convince people who are anti-vaxxed that
you are trustworthy you are crazy
and you're particularly crazy when you
simultaneously say that speech is your
core value
so youtube recently announced susan wash
kiki
she recently announced that
youtube's core value is free speech also
we are going to be suppressing
particular apps from alexandria who is
vladimir putin's chief rival
and now a lot of people are going to
look at this and they're going to say
you mean the same company that is
suppressing rivals to vladimir putin is
suppressing anti-vaxx content weird how
that works it doesn't seem like people
who are committed to the truth it seems
like people who are committed to
whatever gets them ahead today
that would not be a wild conclusion to
draw here's susan wash kiki
one of the things that were
is important to us at youtube is the
fact that we do enable so many voices
and that we do enable people to
express themselves and really celebrate
the freedom of speech
um and we certainly you know that's
that's a core value of ours navalny said
that youtube deleted a video one of his
videos was that
at the request of the russian government
i mean we certainly we certainly get
requests from governments um and
and we
look and consider what's you know why
are we getting the requests what's
actually happening on the ground um and
based on a whole bunch of different
factors we make a decision
okay would those bunch of different
factors be making money in coordination
with governments like the russian
government or like the bide
administration would those have anything
to do with anything at all funny how all
of the people on the left who are
constantly worried about big tech and
government working together the threats
of centralized power suddenly when it
comes to the governments that they like
telling big tech what to do they are
very much in favor of the hijacking of
big tech in favor of their favorite
policy proposals fascinating how that
works okay meanwhile over the last
couple of days while i was out for the
final of the jewish holidays so don't
worry i won't be taking any more breaks
in the near future
over the past couple of days there have
been a bunch of hearings in the senate
over the debacle in afghanistan and it
is well worth pointing out that now
finally after you know we've been out of
there for about a month and a hundred
americans are still trapped behind enemy
lines minimum and thousands of green
card holders are trapped behind there
and tens of thousands of siv holders are
trapped behind enemy lines with the
taliban hanging people in central
squares in cities like harat
and cutting off hands again
and pushing women back into the basement
and all that now we're finding out that
this was all a bad idea who could have
thunk who could have thunk
general milly the all-powerful almighty
general mark milley he came out and said
oh yeah we lost the war yeah no no bleep
sherlock you did well done
there's a whole series of decisions that
take place over 20 years
i don't think that whenever you get some
phenomena like a war that is lost and it
has been in the sense of we accomplished
our strategic task of protecting america
against al qaeda but certainly the end
state is a whole lot different than what
we wanted so whenever the phenomenon
like that happens there's an awful lot
of causal factors and we're gonna have
to figure that out
oh well i mean one of those possible
factors would have been the complete
withdrawal of american troops without
any sort of plan for upholding the
afghan military withdrawing all air
support withdrawing all civilian
contractors and then withdrawing the
military before any of the civilians
could leave maybe ha i don't know just a
guess i had a couple of guesses there i
think maybe some of them are accurate
then millie apparently in a in a
confidential briefing he apparently
directly blamed the state department he
said officials waited too long to order
the operation out of kabul's airport
two days of testimony from millie
defense secretary lloyd austin and
general frank mckenzie head of centcom
underscored the finger-pointing and deep
divisions between state and the pentagon
lawmakers are demanding accountability
over the biden administration's chaotic
exit from afghanistan including the
failure to evacuate thousands of at-risk
afghan allies and leaving without
evacuating all americans the state
department delayed evacuations at the
order of president biden
after afghan president ashkaf ghani
warned that evacuating afghan allies
earlier would destroy morale and lead to
the collapse of the government
during a closed door session after
tuesday's public testimony senator tammy
duckworth directed a general question to
austin about lessons learned from the
withdrawal and millie jumped in to say
the evacuation of civilians needed to
happen earlier
so millie was like it wasn't us it was
the state department remember joe biden
said there was virtual unanimity inside
his administration his military folks
were just backing what he had to say
lies
and general milley also admitted in
testimony that the taliban never broke
affiliation with al-qaeda remember that
time they were saying that the taliban
was helping us fight al qaeda and fight
fight isis and they were really they're
moderating that was all lie
there were seven conditions
applicable to the taliban
and eight conditions applicable to the
united states
while the taliban did not attack u.s
forces which was one of the conditions
it failed to fully honor any
any other condition
under the doha
agreement and perhaps most importantly
for u.s national security
the taliban has never renounced al qaeda
or broke its affiliation with them
oh well um that's that's weird because
you know that might have been helpful
for the american people to know when you
surrender the entire country to them
okay lloyd austin the incompetent
secretary of defense he uh he also
blamed the state department
was it your judgment and opinion that
the evacuations of civilians should have
begun before the middle of august
we provided our input to the state
department and again it is a call of the
state department to i understand that i
understand that mr secretary i'm asking
for what your your judgment was we
provided input to uh to try to get out
as many uh
uh
afghans who have helped us
uh along the way uh as
you know as early as possible uh but
again the state department uh has you
know made its decisions
oh interesting interesting how that
worked you know you didn't see any of
this in real time right in real time
they were all shoulder to shoulder
because your politicians lie to you
political appointees lie to you and just
because they're generals and they're at
the top of the hierarchy does not mean
they're not lying to you okay
there's such a thing as political
generals
many of them get to the top of the
hierarchy specifically because they're
politically adept lloyd austin admitting
oh yeah by the way terrorism is a threat
like as of right now from afghanistan we
were told that it was like two three
years away nope not right now
al qaeda has been degraded over time
now terrorist organizations seek
ungoverned spaces so that they can
uh
train and equip and thrive and and so
there there is clearly a possibility
that that can happen
here uh going forward
and uh and meanwhile frank mckenzie head
of centcom remember who was praising the
taliban and he was talking about how
helpful they were throughout this entire
process um he admits that the taliban
offered the united states control over
kabul so we could evacuate people and
the united states turned it down at the
best of the biden administration they
said no no we only want kabul airport
well only 13 american service members
had to die for that particular decision
here's ken mckenzie
who made the uh the decision to turn
down the taliban offer to allow the u.s
military to secure kabul and put the
safety of our troops in the hands of the
taliban i did not consider that to be a
formal offer and it was not the reason
why i was there so i did not pursue it
so if you're if someone actually made a
decision that would have been me so we
don't know if it was conveyed to the
president we don't know i do know what
was conveyed to my chain of command
okay it was conveyed with chain of
command he just decided oh well what
by the way jin saki now admitting by the
way the generals did in fact want troops
there when joe biden was out there lying
to us saying all of his generals were in
agreement with him that was obviously
unsure at the time and some of us were
pointing out he was lying at the time
here's jinsaki admitting he was lying at
the time
what we're talking about here was an
initial recommendation in the short
initial period of time of having a true
presence that would continue not a
surprise the recommendation over the
course of the last 20 years from the
military has been to maintain a troop
presence you could argue that's their
job to to maintain that the president's
view when given making a risk assessment
when when reviewing his options was that
he did not want to escalate the number
of troops we had in afghanistan he did
not want to risk losing more troops he
did not want to go back at war with the
taliban okay so bottom line it was
biden's call
even while biden was blaming everybody
else what a bleep show this
administration is i mean truly and
honestly it is such a bleep show and
here's the thing joe biden right that's
you know old guy what's waiting in the
wings is way worse than joe biden and
kamala harris is way worse than joe
biden this is why democrats have to be
in a state of low-level panic that is
quickly rising to high high-level panic
i mean they're moving from defcon 3 to
about defcon 2 right now because if they
end up with kamala harris as a candidate
in 2024 after this bleep show of an
administration they are in serious
serious trouble how bad is como harris
by the way kamala harris is so bad at
this that yesterday she was confronted
by a student at some sort of speech and
the students started just spewing
anti-semitic garbage about israel they
said saying that israel was involved in
a quote-unquote ethnic genocide okay
which is just an anti-semitic lie it's
just a jew-hating lie it is there is no
support for it and kamala harris because
she's incompetent and terrible it does
immediately granted a credence
over the summer there have been like
protests and demonstrations and
astronomical numbers standing with
palestine but then just a few days ago
there were funds allocated to continue
backing israel which hurts my heart
because it's
an ethnic genocide and the displacement
of people the same that happened in
america
okay and kamala harris nods well that is
happening and then she suggested quote
i'm glad you did about this girl asking
the question i'm glad you did i'm glad
you did again this is about the fact
that your voice your perspective your
experience your truth should not be
suppressed
whoo okay so that's waiting in the wings
for the democrats no wonder they are in
a state of panic they should be they
should be this administration isn't
here's the thing whether or not they
pass this bipartisan infrastructure bill
whether or not they pass this budget
bill they've got a major problem on
their hands and they should they're bad
at governing their ideas are wrong and
their politicians are both
incompetent and and poor at their actual
public-facing jobs
all of which
you know says that there is not a bright
future for this particular
administration alrighty then we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
an additional hour of content coming up
soon the matte wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show